what is my favorite book series ever
a the Twilight Saga B 50 Shades C Harry
Potter it's Harry it's Harry I know I
was too easy though too easy you knew it
was going to be too easy yeah what else
you had
do you know I did
it's a bit of a sauce it's a bit of a
raw point for me but I did the test on
the Pottermore website which is the
legit one and I'm actually in Hufflepuff
and I was really upset about that to
begin with but then I read why and
actually I think yeah why why
hufflepuffs are actually very loyal
friends and very hard-working people
that makes sense and I thought I got a
real friend and yeah they yeah plus
Cedric Diggory was in Hufflepuff and
he's a g so there you go